[Music]
right now i just want to get some tips
on
basically putting my life on hold
whether
or not to
move basically i have a daughter and i
want to
be in her life
at the same time i have a job that is
really crippling me and has a lot of
negativity involved it's not adding any
value to my life and the timing with my
daughter is limited so if you can give
any tips on putting what you value and
kind of chasing after that as opposed to
holding on to a job which contains your
you know
i have my health insurance my life
insurance
car insurance all that stuff through
them um how long do you do you really
want to put that stuff on hold
so john you
talk about this quite a bit on your show
which folks can check out on youtube by
the way people call in all the time and
some of the craziest calls is like my
wife has cheated on me three times today
and also uh my boss fired me this
morning what do i do
and so you you deal with some of these
complex problems but like what justin is
saying here
your
your book really covers this because you
you talk about the stories that we tell
ourselves and right now one of the
stories is he's given himself the either
or story
and so maybe you what would you say to
justin anytime you've backed yourself
into an either or corner you need to go
talk to somebody because you have
you've limited your options moving
forward and very very rarely do we only
have two options moving forward very
very rarely
um
i would love for his name justin yeah
i'd love for justin to go back and
listen to the call because he answers it
himself
he is drowning himself
with car insurance and health insurance
and a 401 match
he knows that he's dying
yet he lives in a culture where the
story used to be our religious
institutions told us what to wear what
to believe how to function who's who who
got to own property who did all the
stuff and we pulled the threat on that
one
and then we moved to you complete me to
our spouses we dumped everything on them
and that one lasted about 25 years and
we've looked around we've burned our
spouses to the ground right
and our last great bastion of human
connection is work and so now we've
taken our identities and our self-worth
and everything about us and we've dumped
it into the workplace and said y'all
solve us
and so he has a little girl who is
saying to herself every day what is it
about that place that is more lovable
than me
and he is asking himself why am i doing
this and he can't unhook himself from
that last
great vacuum right it's like reminds me
of spaceballs with
mega made she's just like sucking that
dude in right like
he asks when should i right now
right now and if you have to sell your
house and move to a one bedroom
apartment to reconnect with your
daughter and work down the street for 14
hour right now
and you will find peace and freedom and
a clarity to then say what do i do next
but dude right now you know what i mean
you don't have time to wait on those
kind of calls mm-hmm yeah
yeah it's
i don't know it makes me think of when i
first started the whole
minimalism journey
we started the blog i was still working
on my corporate job for about a year and
then i got laid off
and you know luckily i had been
preparing myself to
leave that job eventually
and the amount of clarity that i was
able to gain
after i got laid off just kind of seeing
a path forward and looking at different
options i never would have seen those
different options if i if i didn't get
laid off yeah and thank god they laid me
off because i kept telling myself i'll
quit next month no i'll put on my two
weeks to notice the next month and i
kept putting it off um and it was kind
of forced upon me but you know really
what justin's looking for here is
security he's looking for some certainty
and we all need some security and
certainty and he's finding it right now
in health insurance and car insurance in
the 401k match
but you know justin i would uh
i would challenge you to look at what
what are your bare necessities to really
feel secure
because a 401k match it's a great thing
awesome it's it's amazing um but
you don't need that to feel secure
yeah there's
there's some there's a very interesting
phrase that he used in the call
when he's considering putting his life
on hold
and what i would say is you've already
done that
and so why not consider taking your life
off hold on push play on your life it's
time to press play it may not look like
what society has dictated with the 401k
match and the so-called perfect job
because guess what that perfect job is
making you miserable so how perfect
could it be
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free